hey youtubers it's Charlie so you may
have heard the news about the Teen
Titans TV show good news bad news
situation the bad news is TNT is not
moving forward with it it's completely
dead in the water the good news is that
means all those characters are free to
be used in the movies and the TV shows
you may have heard me talked during
arrow season 3 last year about how there
was a felicity smoak origin story they
were telling it was going to be called
Oracle that was the name of the episode
Warner Brothers then asked them to
change the title because they had other
plans quote-unquote other plans for the
Oracle character nothing else was said
but at the time they were currently they
were still developing this live-action
Teen Titans show the only characters
that they had named for the show though
were Nightwing Starfire and Raven they
hadn't announced the Oracle character
but my assumption was is that oh they
just want a bookmark Barbara Gordon
Oracle for the Teen Titans show if it
goes forward so now you understand why
certain characters like Nightwing for
example I know everyone wants Nightwing
to show up on arrow have not done so
already because when you listen to all
the TV producers not just the arrow on
flash producers but anyone that does a
DC TV show they say that they always
have a running list of characters
they're allowed to use if they have big
characters they can use they will
totally use them like they would totally
do Batman in a heartbeat if they can do
Batman but now that TNT has officially
passed on the project all the Teen
Titans characters are free to be used
wherever Warner Brothers allows them to
be used now cyborg is an old school
member of the Teen Titans he's going to
appear in Justice League and he has a
solo movie coming so they could always
work some of the Teen Titans characters
into the cyborg movie now the problem
with Nightwing he'd be like the biggest
character you do first because you
already have Batman Nightwing Dick
Grayson you get the idea the problem is
is that a lot of people think that this
dead Robin here is Dick Grayson and not
Jason Todd if it really does end up
being Dick Grayson then Nightwing is
completely off the table but there's
still a whole bunch of other Teen Titans
looking you do Starfire if they want to
get cosmic I don't know if they're ready
for it yet but you have changeling Raven
Wonder Girl Raven is also kind of a
problem because you get into these
really supernatural things and they
haven't really done that yet in the Zack
Snyder movie universe I think they'll
get there eventually though they're
doing Green Lantern stuff so if they're
gonna be doing space based stuff
eventually they're probably gonna do
supernatural stuff too it just it takes
them a little while to get there
or for those that are asking I don't
feel like there's gonna be any Teen
Titans movie anytime soon if they felt
like that franchise was strong enough to
sustain a movie they would have already
put it on the books they've already got
so many Justice League solo titles that
I don't think they have room for a Teen
Titans movie maybe after they get
through a couple of the Man of Steel
sequels I think once they introduced the
Justice League universe everything is
gonna change they'll be much more open
to doing bigger movies like this but
just do not expect to hear anything
about Teen Titans characters in any of
the movies before justice league that
has a long ways up which is why they're
also probably going to be open to doing
some Teen Titans related things on the
TV shows now maybe not all the
characters like cyborg probably just
gonna be a movie character they're
probably not gonna let him on any of the
TV shows Wonder Girl does feel like she
would work on Supergirl just because
they have a comparable power level but
changeling Beast Boy have you want to
think about him he would work really
well on the flash they tend to do the
more fantastical things and of course
because they introduced the Deathstroke
character on arrow you could totally do
his family and really pending
availability for Manu Bennett to come
back I feel like that is the best route
to a Teen Titans storyline even if it's
only an arc and they don't do a big
season full of Teen Titans stuff now
rewind all the way back to arrow season
2 this is a while ago they kind of did
the ravager character with Isabel rochev
but Jericho is still alive in this
universe his son is still alive most of
you who read the classic Teen Titans
stories are probably familiar with the
Judas contract it's like the most famous
Teen Titans storyline of all time what
it was between issues 42 of the Teen
Titans comic in the annual number three
they did this arc where they revealed
the identity of Deathstroke the
Terminator as Slade Wilson it introduced
the Jericho character and it brought
hive crumbling down to its knees what is
the name of the organization of the big
bads on arrow this season hive so
naturally Judas contract would be an
awesome storyline for future season of
arrow the only real problem with that is
that Manu Bennett just signed on to a
new series called the shannara
chronicles' which is shooting so if that
continues to get picked up they could be
trouble trying to shoot with him but it
would be an awesome storyline to bring
death stroke to his full potential
for those that haven't read the Teen
Titans comics Deathstroke was just their
greatest villain so anytime
do a big Deathstroke story it's a good
opportunity to do Teen Titans characters
that's why I think Warner Brothers needs
to allow Greg Berlanti and his group of
producers to use these Teen Titans
characters now they don't need every
single character that was ever called a
Titan they just need enough so that you
could call it a meaningful Teen Titans
story in a Teen Titans TV show would be
an awesome replacement for arrow after
arrow gets done in like season 7 or
however many seasons it ends up going
just a little bit more hardcore a little
bit more comic book II but it gets even
better
let's throw some more gasoline on this
fire Andrew Kreisberg who is the
executive producer - the showrunner of
the flash just signed an overall deal
with Warner Brothers to develop new
television shows for the network that
means that he is looking for new
properties to develop in one of his
favorite comic books of all time next to
the flash of course is Teen Titans so
you have a makeup producer looking for
something to develop you have a show
that's dead at another network so a
bunch of characters are freed up just do
the math I feel like they're already
having conversations about this behind
the scenes now that doesn't mean
anything's gonna happen and it's almost
too late in the season to do like big
big arcs with these new characters so
even if they do get the OK from Warner
Brothers to use Teen Titans characters
you won't see any of them on arrow or
the flash until the fall until like the
next season
what about legends of tomorrow wouldn't
they also work really well on that show
that's kind of a different bag because
it's so much grander I feel like that
would be a good place to introduce the
Starfire character maybe maybe in all
the Teen Titans characters usually when
they introduce new characters on TV
shows it's relative to what that shows
Jana is like the flash tends to be a
little bit more powers based so if it's
a super powerful character with really
awesome comic-book powers it's probably
gonna happen on the flash but if it's a
character that's a little more based in
crime drama like Nightwing he's probably
gonna show up on arrow just because
that's what that shows all about so let
me know in the comments where do you
want to see these characters show up and
which ones do you want to see in the
movies and which ones do you think that
they'll be able to do on the TV shows
and which TV shows do you want them to
be on just remember the Supergirl is
only tangentially connected to arrow on
the flash so if a character shows up on
Supergirl
it doesn't automatically guarantee that
they'd be able to show up on arrow or
flash that's still kind of like
crossover a gray area until the kings of
the CBS castle give their
thumbs up Supergirl can't go on the
flash but I do think it'll happen
eventually
she actually just won a People's Choice
Awards so if you see Supergirl on the
street give her a giant high-five in
case you didn't see the flash video I
posted the other day I mentioned that
they're gonna be doing special legends
of tomorrow press this weekend that'll
be my next arrow flash related video
they'll probably be dropping a whole
bunch of news in the really awesome
thing they just announced Jewel Staite
from Firefly is gonna guest star on
legends of tomorrow as a comic book
character they didn't say which one
she's gonna be only that it's gonna be
science-based she'll be a scientist so
new round of the reverse flash giveaway
still going on all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video I'll just
announce the winner whenever I post that
next legends of tomorrow video so much
awesome stuff happening yeah it sucks
the Teen Titans is dead but that just
means that they can use the characters
on other shows so do not be bumped out
at all this is good news why you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here to learn all about king shark
coming back to the flash gonna be big
arrow crossover and you can click here
for my daredevil season 2 teaser trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight